الا بروكسل حيث يعقد وزراء طاقه
الاوروبيون اجتماعا في محاولات الاتفاق
على سطل لاسعار الغاز وذلك بعد فشلهم في
التواصل الى توافق خلال شهور الماضيه يعد
هذا الاجتماع الخامس منذ صيف هذا العام في
محاوله لتقليل اسعار الكهرباء الاخيره في
الاتحاد الاوروبي ياتي الاجتماع وصل
انخفاض متزايد في درجات الحراره في مختلف
الدول الاوروبيه وصلها هذا الاسبوع الى ما
بين خمس وعشر درجات تحت الصفر و تشهد هذه
الاجتماعات الخلافات حول سقف السعر حيث
تطرح المفوضيه الاوروبيه سعر
225$ للميجاوات فيما ترغب اثنتا عشره دوله
اوروبيه بين هذا بلجيكا وايطاليا خفضه الى
مدينه 200 دولار
وفي العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس انطلقت اشغال
ومؤتمرين لدعم اوكرانيا يهدف المؤتمر
الاول الذي تشارك فيه نحو 70 دوله ومنظمه
دوليه الى تربيه احتياجات اوكرانيا لتجاوز
فصل الشتاء ويركز المؤتمر الثاني الثنائي
بين فرنسا واوكرانيا على مشاركه الشركات
الفرنسيه في اعاده اعماره اوكرانيا
ومعنى من باريس مراسل الجزيره حافظ الذي
يتابع اجواء مداولات هذين المؤتمرين حافظ
نعم حسن في الحقيقه ما زالت اعمال للمؤتمر
الاول وهو مؤتمر التضامن مع اوكرانيا كما
قدمته سلطات الفرنسيه الان ما زال متواصلا
سمعنا كلمات الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون
للرئيس الاوكراني فولودي ميرسي لرئيس
الوزراء الاوكراني رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه
بالاضافه الى عده مسؤولين اخرين خلال هذه
القمه الهدف الاساسي هو تقديم الدعم
الطارق لاوكرانيا لمواجهه فصل الشتاء
وبروده الطقس هناك بحسب ما كذه الرئيس
خلال كلمته الافتتاحيه قال ان مجموعه
الدعم المنتظر تقديمه او العود التي تم
تقديمها الى حد الان يبلغ نحو 400 مليون
يورو وقال ان هذا الرقم مرجح للارتفاع
خلال المؤتمر وبعده
اثناء الرئيس زيننسكي قال ان بلاده تحتاج
الى نحو الثمانين 100 مليون يورو لتجاوز
فصل الشتاء وتداعيتي بروده الطقس على
المدنيين والسكان في اوكرانيا قال ان
اوكرانيا تحتاج الى عده معدات لتوليد
الطاقه لاصلاح
ومولدات الطاقه ولكن ايضا لاصلاح كل
الاعطاب التي يخلفها القصف الروسي
بالاضافه الى تربونات غاز والى دعم كما
قال زينب من شبكه الطاقه الاوروبيه ايمان
ما كان وقال ان فرنسا ستقدم نحو سته
وسبعين فاصل خمسه مليون يورو اضافيه لدعم
اوكرانيا على على ايجاد حاجيتها الطارئه
لفصل هذا الشتاء بالاضافه الى 200 مليون
يورو كانت قد اعلنت فرنسا عنها في وقت
السابق في الحقيقه اغلب الكلمات تمحورت
حول الدعم القارئ وكيفيه ايصاله لاوكرانيا
خلال هذه المرحله العناوين هي الطاقه
الصحه ايضا البنا التحتيه الاساسيه مثل
شبكات المياه شبكات النقل ولكن ايضا الصحه
والمستشفيات وكيفيه دعمها لمن للمكرون
تحدث عن وضع اليه باريس كما قال من اجل
تجميع كل المساعدات الانسانيه الطارئه
لاوكرانيا وذلك عبر اليه الدفاع المدني
الاوروبي لكي تصل هذه المساعدات الى
المستحقها في الوقت اللازم كما قالوا
الاشاره الى ان ارسل لين رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه قالت ان المفوضيه قدمت نحو 19
مليار يورو الى اوكرانيا ك- دعم ماليه
خلال العام الماضي وسد تقدم خلال الفتره
المقبله نحو 18 مليار اضافيه سيتم تقديمها
شهريا لدعم ميزانيه اوكرانيا
ريد احمر واصل للجزيره من باريس شكرا لك